our mission Malcolm both motto forgot I
have some green tea Parliament's nahin
lemon and year anja rubik corona Haru
and emmalin Devore taken as the dark
attachment a marvelous
I Malcolm the returning officer for the
nehalem a venir parliamentary
constituency give notice that the number
of votes recorded for each candidate at
the said election was as follows
like either gain markus anthony Torian
August good to know
the ha'la'tha neither docus discordia
throne marc anthony scottish
conservative and unionist 1200
keramik young of the year stoma Halawa
me the die-cut sequoia karmic John
Scottish Christian party 1045 para
gosden you ready liberally jamoke the
thought in Halawa KF here lately at
satya ferguson Buehrle Scottish Liberal
Democrats 456 McNeil the nurse Briana
party national in Halawa for Camilla she
appeared sleepy cat cigar
mcneil Angus Brendan scottish national
party SNP each day morriston Alistair on
earth party lava rock Mahalo per km
either Poyet is 3pm
Morrison Alistair Angus Scottish Labour
Party 4560
but I you get circadian table in both
these aren you'll see the number of
ballot papers rejected was 44
for three fifths of 3g oak playing a key
here till night as a kid the turnout was
72 the point four percent agus motion
amia jariabek you Val Ernest Rhiannon
McNeil Aaron hug Marvel Parliament of
Sun rain ty McGill ananya and I declare
that Angus Brendan McNeil is duly
elected to serve as Member of Parliament
but in the hill at an idea
a third window she's a tank divorce
kunafa Catherine Malkin birth and a
Polish were popular as station 3 and the
clocks in the pooch yes care in the
cocoon dish in the bush harvest new yet
for the kids I guess the carriage
enacted 14 gaha he cook is she a
creature sherry keyboard a shell the
caliper the real culture show you see
here garage more a show and SNP can I
thank you the returning officer mark
Canberra the police the staff at the
election boots the polling stations the
counting staff especially those in table
for under colleagues and one two three
five and six as well this is indeed a
big night for Scotland and a massive
night for the SNP I understand I
understand that since 1945 the SNP is
only one 33 seats at the general
election in 70 years let's see what we
have tonight tonight if Labour one at
Westminster Scotland has leverage if the
Tories one request mr. Scotland has
moral authority we have this because we
have voted SNP across Scotland and this
vote is about to end austerity are
ruinous economic policy and it's
something of hope for those in England
to the SNP are very cognizant of her
friends in England it is also don't
mistake it a mandate for full fiscal
responsibility for Scotland do you
enable Scotland to end the austerity
have just talked about and follow the
path of saints underpinned by Nobel
Prize winners such as Paul Krugman and
Joe Stiglitz and also the writer Mark
Blythe it is to better the lives of the
pool are not end with a crushing welfare
policies such as the bedroom tax we've
seen emanating from Westminster in the
last few years austerity always ends
because it loses at the ballot box not
because of any economic reasons people
get fed up with austerity in Scotland we
had a party to end austerity far as the
SNP and we will do our best to end
austerity can I finally thank my team
can I thank the SNP members who've done
fantastically again ten years ago we won
the first seat from labor in 34 years at
the general election in the hiligaynon
year and it looks like the rest of
Scotland will a decade later follow the
healing in a year and on a final
personal note can I thank my neighbors
as well Sheamus McLean and English food
looked after my sheep shooting this
general election campaign powerful
volley sure